here with reaction fox news legal
analyst greg jarrett along with former
white house chief of staff reince
priebus you know writes
there's no logical sense to defund
dismantle
or nobel laws none whatsoever but it's
being adopted by every blue state and it
seems like every blue city in america
and it's and it's gone viral and they
seem fine with it i'm having a hard time
understanding why they think that's a
good issue to run on
well it's not a good issue shauna if you
look at the number one and number two
issues across america you alluded to it
in the last segment it's crime and
inflation and that's why you have
governor candidates across this country
in your state of new york talking about
firing district attorneys on day one in
wisconsin and other states look at the
crime rate in portland up 800 percent
philly dc i mean you name it but here's
the interesting thing about these
democrats the proof is in the pudding
because there's two
things that come out in the last month
that totally debunk what the democrats
have been talking about and that is two
things number one
stacey abrams how much money has she
spent on personal security four hundred
and fifty thousand dollars for her own
personal security in the meantime she's
handing out grants to candidates who are
espousing the idea of defunding the
police second thing
it came out this past week how much
money is joe biden spending in putting a
fence
around his home nearly in delaware uh
500 000
when on day one in an executive order
when he was president he signed an
executive order
not to not deport uh illegal immigrants
who committed a crime and to stop
building the wall i mean these guys are
total complete hypocrites you know greg
this is like you know a squared b
squared equals c squared if you allow
law breaking you allow violence you
allow theft and you don't punish people
and you have no bail laws and people get
rearrested and let free every time
this is a predictable result you don't
have to be an mit grad or a harvard
business school grad to figure this out
yeah but the far left liberals and the
woke progressives think it's fashionable
to care about the criminal while
ignoring the law-abiding innocent
victims of crime that are being
terrorized in their own community a
gallup poll just out shows that 80
percent of americans are really worried
about being victims of crime they fear
for their lives
but the woke mob
you know thinks that uh it's really
important to let criminals go free
because they're horribly misunderstood
people um we're to blame for that
they're not to blame for it society is
guilty uh so they've instituted these
insane policies which is defunding
police installing incompetent judges
uh castles bail
decriminalizing
serious felonies down to mere
misdemeanors reducing sentencing for
major crimes and releasing hardboard
criminals out of prisons and jails the
inevitable result
is
lawlessness and and crime every major
category of crime has skyrocketed from
shootings murders stabbings theft
larceny you name it uh and you know
american voters are also to blame
because they installed these far left
liberals that run these states and
cities and until they
finally say we've had enough they have
the ultimate veto power and they can get
rid of these elected officials
if if reince
you know politics as well as anybody if
every republican running runs on a law
and order platform runs on an education
platform that empowers parents and gets
rid of wool curriculum if they run on
energy independence and they run on
lowering taxes not raising taxes and
they run on the idea of securing our
border
how could they lose in this environment
don't you think that the american people
have had it with all of this record high
gas prices record inflation record crime
uh record amounts of people entering the
country illegally
yeah you're you're 100 correct
republicans have to stick to the 80
percent winners it's what newt gingrich
used to teach at gopec all the time do
you believe we should secure the border
protect the american worker and our
children yes or no yes do you think that
violent criminals that have committed
felonies that hurt people should be let
go and on in cashless bail so they can
run their car through a waukesha county
parade the answer is no and if we stick
do should parents have a say over their
kids education and whether teachers
should be teaching kids incessantly
about
you know transgender
issues across the board the answer is no
they shouldn't we parents should have a
say so
if you stick to the 80 and keep it
simple in this environment with this
president that screwed everything up the
republicans should not be losing
anywhere and i don't think they will i
think it's going to be a great year
all right i hope you're right it's the
senate's always tough especially we have
every bellwether state um you know
as you know
not every state is going to be an easy
uh run for the republican side because
they are you know middle states we'll
see what happens we'll see if this
becomes a wave election which i hope it
can be hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else